the Big Apple and snacks is hungry he's
got one kill already on the USP low HP
as well on Guardian and flame he's
trying to guys the pistol round is like
the great equalizer in any game of csgo
I love them obviously it doesn't matter
how badly you lost in the last half or
even the last game when the pistol round
comes around it's like wiping the slate
clean
oh and hey even if you bought a pistol
you know forced by situation or against
a full buy and it's not actually the
pistol round it's still where some of
the hype is play in csgo can happen Hawk
comes in for apex going off right now so
leave your SMGs your shotguns your
rifles all of them at home this week on
best of we're talking about the best
pistol plays in csgo
now we've got plays from the 50 caliber
killer known as the desert eagle
we've got plays from the silent but
deadly USPS get in and plays from the
rest of these so-called secondary
arsenals position he's looking to jump
up on the sky and he's gonna do it there
Oh what so let's get this best of pistol
play started with a crowd-pleaser
the desert eagle nice
voila whoaaaa needs to dodge the
flashbang and they use those to get our
goal
we're free deeds back to back to back
off dick no what's up Dominic can sell
open things up I just does get one back
and actually all these are hitting the
floor - get with a second is the doing
damage at range okay magic he's been a
bit of a king or with the pistol has his
deadly vegan hand starts to peek into
this now he's on four has to wait for
the wind he's gonna go ahead and do it
magic bad nines already kind of taken
this gamble stack with the force by
Susie's and armor who wears a bumps and
it looks like Russian hotty are gonna
start things up for the kill each and
it's looking like even trades across the
board right now it's three on three and
still with a big one he switched from
the pit to pit over one year as well and
he had two bullets in the gun two
bullets the one day called Sarah
fighting to keep his team afloat in this
first half four rounds is definitely not
very good here on CT side of Morocco
taking down Dennis flexing you know
playing very patient still two players
back by IV one man wants the site and
there it is automatic that's incredible
for automatic as he finds a third as
well but how have they let him walk in
no one even looking at him and they know
they're against pistols he's got four
edge Johnson he's going for the a stall
ready of automatic talk about a fever
yeah he's looking very hot Mouse's by is
gonna be torn away from them very very
quickly by sidekick oh my god shocks
then that's justify one more the money
isn't gonna touch him and what on earth
has just happened as deagle is on fire
shock just gonna walk into as well Niko
is on fire to free play it bags could
swing back in that direction because the
air isn't going to be pressure he needs
to know that
[Applause]
at least if you plant open there's
there's a shot for him to do something
if you can stay alive but it just didn't
happen that way but okay
gonna fly in a little bit but still have
enough vision to win the exchange and
the round I would say it's going to
following my passion is SK have control
or do they oh my goodness automatic for
HP when it comes to default pistols in
csgo I don't know about you but I think
of the USPS what you got there is hiu SB
9 now extended Mac it's my personal
favor it costs you nothing as a CT and
even outside of the pistol round has the
ability to win entire rounds that is if
you have the aim to back it up are you
kidding me out sure the p2000 is
comparable but if you really want to
role play as a stealthy assassin the
USPS is where it's at I mean every gun
that they save just makes the play that
little bit easier and a little bit more
profitable as well they're gonna have
far more money so just no reason to hunt
it if there's no benefit they're
probably not gonna win the round anyway
and yeah dennis is even catching frags
on the exit the USP 2 kills probably
called 0 and bolt and Ogden forward
Dennis we know he's the pistol master
than that a little bit too much smarter
than Robbie
this is their smoke and now OAC doubled
up that's criminal
pazi's left in unreal down in CT wants
to try and get more done and oh my
goodness AZ the Aces easy steps up that
fight between SIF NYX and Kenny which is
one pretty quickly that's important
waiting close he's gonna get completely
truck by shops and apex gets a head shot
then sold on city's alone he gets one
the bomb is right in front of him he's
flicking through the smoke and missing
the last couple of shots body is honored
with the diffused kid he's gonna get one
kill sip for this rock oh my god he
picks it up for now running back in he's
got the quad he's looking for the X no
more bullets though you kidding me
please can be used to playing at a bog
of the size itself but Sevilla is trying
to hide by the battle thanks be the
first to engage but he'll be did battle
pretty quickly this is your taking the
shot fighting getting in how is that how
is this real life that is beautiful skin
that's the stuff
good mechanics doesn't you train dude
getting up quick two fighters from VP
though on that a bomb sight task getting
ruined immediately after taking out my
co now USP master out here oh where it
is bending bullets today oh are you
kidding
okay clip it clip it I just called him a
USP faster and then he delivered that
none of those shots made any sense
second as well and it's all holding a
bob headshot on Valda
and now on pic just he's got the bomb
sight but not much else well that's
ridiculous apex is gone and I bet he has
no idea why you have two players there
who need to get by and obviously the
presence and that
extremely I love that they need to do it
now it's a good trait to start off with
kW going down cold Syrah and now next
action is this one of my standing or
struck LG they need to move fast
otherwise their recitation is coming
Matic there's a good push going in in
Phoenix picking up one all up with the
refracts Phoenix and how are triple and
he's trying to see if I can pick up this
USPS he's got the bomb right there buddy
can't make it down the stairwell and
he's alone in this one on two he's
finally got the farm just getting the
palm down he's gonna have to take the
fight there for one shot everything
in the real
the rest of csgo sidearm arsenal is
nothing to scoff at either the p250 and
the five-seven are still absolute beasts
when it comes to contact play and you
already know the cz-75 is the bane of
any full buy and the tec-9 exists how's
the tech man jumping I don't know man
and hey even dual Berettas and the r8
are still deadly if you manage to click
on somebody's head this is gonna be very
interesting
here they come he's gonna try to peek
that pre-emptive he goes out there Julie
sets the first kill coming on to groove
he gets the second as well uh I guess
the bud that Julie's are gonna rain and
true if gonna try and get some work done
no Molotov to use as a smoke on the site
anyway foresters picked up ward can he
go any better than that he knows
[Applause]
Eli's actually gets it now so that's
very doable here is the practice coming
through Freiburg finds one on to death
but he's just on two apps they should
close this down very momentarily the Bob
Davie is coming out all away but
actually manages get what he's done this
before it's the one one situations all
right Millie this would be absolutely
disgusting here Android needs to shut
this down probably just he needs to play
time this is his rounds lose now he's
taking over for what situation is gonna
get but there you have it and now it's
hiko one on five dreiberg has already
made his mark to make sure that they won
the round
Kiko is gonna go for it private will
eventually follow but it is too late
Gerrard is gonna be waiting he coaches
in reactions the killing blow
it doesn't like a biscuit it'll
certainly can't how did he get to that
and tarik just snapping around is able
to hold the line from jungle as well
they'll pull the round back she gets
that one yeah he did
wait what's happening I didn't even see
it on the first three Friday I know
every 2000 puffins that's not so yet now
there you go that's way sicker what do
they do they pick her head II what what
okay so twitch is getting this Creek
triple kill so all of a sudden the round
is actually possible for liquids away
that of nowhere Oscars alone and he gets
completely overwhelmed so twist
absolutely nowhere clutches hook that
round for Team Liquid and he's got the
time that efuses bomb as well that let's
see this again from this perspective
two of them stack up and then the third
kills what's the one that's most
impressive instantly gets bad shot all
the one clip as well
opteka is gonna stay inducing keep them
so pretty much
what it would have an important round
that was done oh my gosh right what the
actual hell was that
headshots vac get that man testes
where are the needs at there aren't any
responsible if they didn't have enough
money or they've already used them
there's one ball atop going in now that
the kill start to trickling for
responsibles on the 69 it will once
again just be eco the about the block
yeah well we've got three from behind
quad can he find a fourth he gets the so
Dignitas have a great opportunity to
catch up and JW has brought something
disgusting bad you serious
maybe he's been practicing hot maybe he
you know it's the secrets hey we need JW
cam because I don't care what else
happened know that was made look at get
right he's gonna go for the style play
does he'll have the drop does he land
the jump Ben call it now does he do it
no it's gonna ignore of me
this position he's looking to jump up on
the sky and he's gonna do it there Oh
what get right tag it down device
mid-air with the tech 9 device is going
to be furious absolutely furious about
that how does that even happen look at
this let's let's relive the glory of
this right that's well guys that's all
we got for you on best of this week now
if you want more content like this
squeeze the trigger on the subscribe
button and ring that Bell like you're
warming up on inferno
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]